ما القاسم المشترك بين لعبة Game of Thrones والمصارع الذي
تم تصويره في هذه الصحراء المغربية
[تصفيق
] ليس سراً أن بعض أفلامنا وبرامجنا
التلفزيونية المفضلة لم يتم تصويرها بالضبط
في الموقع الذي كنا نتوقعه ولكن Alice
Studios في المغرب قد يكون لديها  بعض
من أكثر المواقع تنوعًا
داخل جدران الاستوديو الخاصة بها في خطوات فقط ،
يمكنك الانتقال من الشعور وكأنك في
مصر القديمة إلى قلعة من القرون الوسطى إلى
معبد بوذي ، لطالما كانت المنطقة
خيارًا شائعًا لهوليوود
بدءًا من لورنس العرب  في عام 1962
منذ ذلك الحين ، تم استخدامه لأفلام
مثل Aladdin The Mummy و
gladiator والبرامج التلفزيونية مثل Game of
Thrones Atlantis و Prison Break ،
يعد الاستوديو واحدًا من أكبر الأستوديو في
العالم حيث تبلغ مساحته أكثر من 300 ألف قدم مربع.
تنبع الشعبية من
مناخها الموثوق الذي يمكن أن يحاكي مجموعة
متنوعة من البلدان ،
نرحب بالسياح لزيارة الموقع ، لكنها ستكون
مغامرة من صنعك لأن Alice
studio لا يزال يستخدم كمكيف  مجموعة أفلام tive
ومع ذلك يمكنك تحديد موعد جولة إرشادية
لسماع كل شيء عن مجموعة الأسرار